martin biron au christian dufour hélène
budget ti bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir un mot
quand même c'était le tour de makoko
vrai qu'aujourd'hui procès donc à pékin
lui je veux faire entendre monsieur
trudeau qui dit s'appuyer sur les autres
pays qui appuient le canada dans cette
bataille là on est content
nous allons continuer d'être ferme on a
vu à quel point dépit de partout dans le
monde se sont joints à la préoccupation
des canadiens pour la santé des de
michael et aussi pour les principes de
règles de droit et les valeurs qui nous
sont chères en tant que démocratie d'une
de processus judiciaire qui sont
indépendants et douloureux on va
continuer d'être très clair que cette
détention arbitraire et inacceptable
nous allons continuer de d'exiger d'un
retour hélène j'ai commencé avec vous on
a l'impression que à moins que les
américains décès de laisser faire leur
demande d'extradition donc à moins
qu'ils ne décident de libérer mind
wenzhou on voit mal l'issue de cendres
quand une issue facile pour les deux
canadiens mais clairement le canada
semble être un peu à la remorque de ce
que font les états unis et ce discours
un peu plus musclé qu'on semble entendre
émané d'ottawa semble être à l'image du
fait qu'il ya un nouvel occupant à
washington la maison blanche
monsieur byden s'en prendre plus à coeur
cette cause des 2 maicon et donc on sent
que le canada un peu plus de confiance
dans ce dossier l'homme est clairement
c'est quelque chose qui ce qui veut se
faire collectivement le canada ne veut
pas être seul au front dans cette
bataille
christian duffau peut-être la relation
avec la chine dans les prochaines années
ça va être le gros sujet je parle pas
que du canada mais l'occident face à la
chine là on est en plein dedans nous le
canada clairement pas ce que la chine
n'est pas de tradition diplomatique sur
le plan international traditionnement la
chine était dans son univers elle se
considérait comme le centre du mans la
chine ne comprend que les rapports de
force donc à ce moment là lorsque c'est
simplement un duel entre le canada
hélas chien on ne peut que perdre donc
le développement intéressant quand même
dans ce dossier là dans la mesure où la
7 jours barry john key et aux etats unis
c'est ça être l'alliée du canada je
pense qu'un doigt une au canada dans ce
dossier là parce qu'il faut quand même
le rappeler le sait qu'on est un peu le
dindon de la farce là dedans le sait on
fait le jeu de trompe dans le dossier au
sujet de l'iran plus de canadiens qui
sont menacés de sanctions épouvantable à
cause de ça aussi la communauté
internationale réagit entre autres au
dossier des ouigours qui est une
calamité absolue que j'ai entendu
monsieur legault tantôt pour monsieur
nouveau monsieur trudeau dans tous
rappelé la règle de droit je trouve
qu'on est cependant la règle de droit
n'est dans le refus de la barbarie c'est
beaucoup plus fondamentale que c'est
dans ce centre pour venir votre question
de base source le fiasco pour la chine
sur le plan international parce que
l'eau la chaîne montre un côté d'elle
qui est tellement barbares j'ai pas peur
d'utiliser ce mot là on est en face
d'otages qu'à ce moment là ils vont être
obligés en fait d'assumer fait
dispositif canada c'est pas juste les
états unis c'est toute la communauté
être cela qui dialoguent ça va faire
surtout que c'est quand même la nouvelle
puissance qui me donne pas d'autre choix
que d'essayer de les influencer
je répondais métropole mais de leur
faire comprendre ça marche pas comme ça
mais on est tous en train d'acheter
quand même puis les rapports économiques
restent là martin mais christian
souligné la présence de bail dunn qui
connaît bien si jiping on passe la
présence de baden et que peut-être lui
va va mettre les mots et le poids qui
fauche donne de l'oxygène un peu à
monsieur trudeau ouais sans répéter ce
qu'est ce qu'est ce que disait quand les
collègues et reste que l'on n'allait pas
ce cas peut-être un momentum le
premièrement il
le gouvernement en fait le canada a été
seul pris en sandwich entre la chine et
donald kohn
mais là aujourd'hui on sent que il sait
qu un peu plus de monde derrière le
canada et que effectivement le fait que
monsieur by donne soit là depuis
quelques mois on sentait d'ailleurs dans
ses entrevues que monsieur garneau vous
adonner miss gard nous a donné qu'il y
avait quand même les canaux étaient
ouverts il y avait une discussion
alors y'a peut-être ya peut-être un
moment ok écoutez ça c'est la bonne
entente mois jean françois lépine qui
était impliqué je change de sujet donc
bon à attendre entre messieurs legault
et trudeau francs soit on se tait
pauvres personnes depuis quasiment un an
et là ça fait double 1,18 qu'on se
retrouve tous des belles annonces chute
je t'avoue que ça va très bien le
partenariat qu'on ensemble beige très
content de commencer la semaine pour une
deuxième fois avec le premier ministre
du canada
c'est rendu qu'on s'appelle françois
justin françois justin et la musette
hibon est le courant passait là le
courant c'est le cas de tir passe une
annonce sur l'internet haute vitesse un
enjeu extrêmement important dans la vie
des gens en région
ah oui absolument pas nous qui vivons
dans des grottes grâce entre comprenons
pas nécessairement l'ampleur du problème
mais cette annonce aujourd'hui la bonne
humeur elle était réelle elle était
sincère parce que voici ou deux
intéresse de monsieur legault et de
monsieur legault qui concordent
absolument parfaitement d'abord ottawa
avait déjà mis de l'argent de côté pour
intel pour brancher tout le monde de
vitesse à peu près à 1.75 milliards de
dollars et là le québec lui fait une
fleur en quelque sorte en arrivant avec
un projet clé en main a besoin négocier
tout est déjà fait ottawa vous avez
juste à nous faire le chèque
on me dit à ottawa contre tout va un
petit peu le montant élevé quand même la
parcelle d'à peu près 420 millions mais
aussi mais mon dieu on rénove
ben non alors on est très content d'eux
mais aussi deuxième a faim il faut quand
même le dire en région c'est là où les
libéraux veulent faire des gains
électoraux
ouais martin c'est fait
voilà une bonne annonce monument pour un
objectif noble et payant électoralement
web et monsieur legault avait pas
vraiment le choix de réussir parce que
c'est là oui il est en région c'est là
où il ya ses électeurs il ya des poches
de jal qui sont pas branchés à peu près
partout au québec et ça demandait
énormément de volonté politique pour
réussir ça parce que on l'a vu l'entente
les avec six compagnies deux entreprises
de télécommunications avec des
présidents coriace là il fallait
négocier avec pierre karl péladeau il
fallait négocier avec le président de
bell mirko bibic qu'il fallait négocier
avec le président telus monsieur darren
helm et c'était compliqué et c'était un
ministre délégué qui avait le dossier et
on s'est rendu compte que ça
fonctionnerait pas alors monsieur
legault est une g de s'impliquer
après les rebelles main et honnêtement
quand tu ouvres ton portefeuille
tout est faisable parce que comme le dit
hélène ça coûte cher lloyd ont frôlé le
milliard de dollars soit énormément
d'argent un petit mot là-dessus
christian away cette idylle l'a fait
rentrer françois justesse pour une bonne
nouvelle pour erin et au toulon va
peut-être parler d'en arriver là avec la
pandémie internet est plus nécessaire
que jamais et j'étais content parce que
monsieur legault ses références vous
aussi patrice à une analogie avec
l'électricité car en venant à
radio-canada je pensais moi à maurice
duplessis puis l'office de l'explication
rural quand j'étais jeune moi parce que
je lâche certains j'ai pas connues
seules mais on nous disait humain du
succès objectif de duplessis s'arrêter
l'électrification rurale en 1945 avait
créé un office qui avait réussi son
monsieur le groupe peut-être pas qu'on
le compare à maurice duplessis
mais ça avait été vraiment un enjeu
électoral très très important dans
l'histoire du québec d'avoir la
révolution tranquille c'est vrai que
l'analogie ça ressemble quelque part
très bien a alors écoutez le prochain
extrait
on parle du professeur attaran vers
celle d'ottawa qui compare le québec à
l'alabama
je reviendrai pas sur tout ce qui est
dit donc il n'aime pas beaucoup le
québec il fait savoir
nancy tweed et l'a écouté ça en tant qu
ils aient quoi je suis toujours désolé
quand des gens essayent de de faire
propager des déclarations chocs pour
pour irriter pour avoir un peu de
publicité
on va toujours être là pour défendre la
liberté d'expression mais je pense que
ça va faire le québec bashing j'étais
déçu effectivement de voir que le
recteur l'oci d'ottawa pour condamner et
les propos de son prof et
bath inacceptable alors je commence avec
vous christian knees et le monde
universitaire aussi est-ce que le
recteur de mercy d'ottawa aurait dû
sanctionner
faire quelque chose contre ce prof
rappelons que c'est un souverainiste
c'est un souverainisme a été président
de la commission des droits de la
personne du québec puis une limite aux
deux poids deux mesures parce qu'ils
dirigent une université en fête ou au
dessus que dans les cours la liberté
d'expression est menacée
et là maintenant il fait des leçons sur
la liberté d'expression et paul st
pierre plamondon en compte pas faire de
ce genre de distinction là donc pour
répondre à votre question c'est clair
que c'était son devoir de dénoncer de
dire que c'est totalement inacceptable
dans fait ce genre de déclarations même
si moi je la liberté d'expression c'est
important que je peux quand on empêche
de les faire et aussi la déclaration de
monsieur trudeau sur le québec bashing
franchement on sait une fois n'est pas
coutume moi j'étais content ça sentait
un peu les élections chacun il faut
qu'ils s'occupent du québec un peu plus
que d'habitude je vais finir là-dessus a
laissé la da est disposée à reconnaître
toutes les différences identitaires de
la galaxie mme à l'égard du québec un
problème par moments on a l'impression
que le québec bashing c'est comme
acceptée dans le reste du canada donne
donc un chapeau pour monsieur trudeau de
l'avoir dénoncé ce qu il n louis sortie
saint tin monsieur trudeau qui est à
trois rivières qui ce que lui convaincu
car une élection je le sais pas mais son
temps du début à la fin de la conférence
de presse un ton de ce truc donc on
retrouve plus souvent en campagne un peu
plus direct un peu moins de flafla
ah oui absolument puis en fait il ya
voler les mots de la bouche du bloc
québécois qui a à peu près au même
moment faisait une déclaration en
chambre pour parler de québec bashing
alors il ya quand même eu quand même
c'est si rare que monsieur trudeau dit
les mêmes choses que le bloc local alors
au salon on savait qu'il y avait un
terreau fertile
je suis assez d'accord avec ceux qui
s'en disent hey salut quand elle
sous-entend que monsieur ouattara
traitait le premier ministre de
suprémacistes blancs et qu'il
distribuait les les accusations de
racisme à la volée ça pouvait encore
passer dans la mesure où ça se fait en
dehors des heures de classe
mais il m'apparaît que monsieur attar a
franchi une limite dans un de ces
gazouillis sur twitter quand il a écrit
québécois vous avez élu un gouvernement
qui refuse de reconnaître le racisme
systémique et c'est pour ça que je n'ai
pas de respect pour vous les québécois
et là ils somment avoir franchi la
limite reconnu
le code criminel de la haine
l'incitation à la haine envers un groupe
identifié l'on n'est plus seulement dans
des opinions ont fait une généralisation
complète à propos de quelques individus
au gouvernement qu'on aime pas à propos
de tout un peuple
et là il me semble qui a franchi la
ligne et asperger l'université ne
devrait pas tolérer ça de la part de ses
professeurs parce que ça relève que de
quelque chose qui se trouve un peu
tribunal allemand conclusion ce sujet là
je parlais de me surtout l'après en
conclusion martin weale communion
d'esprit lancar monsieur trudeau
monsieur le haut
mais quand même deux ans deux angles un
monsieur legault s'en est pris à
monsieur frémont le petit quand même
cultive l'art de ce soir entre deux
chaises et de ne pas prendre position
est d'ailleurs la professeur lui tenant
du val mis sur sa page facebook à peine
une heure une déclaration à 10 ans a pas
de bon sens moi j'étais à l'intérieur de
mon court quand j'ai fait ma quand j'ai
parlé du mois est né j'ai eu des
sanctions et lui il dit n'importe quoi
sur twitter puis il ya eu aucune
sanction
monsieur trudeau je pense pouvait pas
perdre en disant ça parce que il n'y
était pas dans ce qu'on entend dans la
déclaration politique en par opposition
lot fédéralistes souverainistes ou moins
français anglais
oui le pipeline d'énergie vieillesse ou
à la péréquation alors là il était
vraiment face à des déclarations qui
avaient pas d'alluré
attaran exagère tellement que facile
tout le monde nous aide qui peut être
d'accord avec ce genre de d'emportement
de désir en fait bon voilà hommes et
surtout voyez vous je refuse je me suis
fait pas ainsi à christian en fin de
semaine j'ai eu une pensée triste
présent ils essaient de moderniser un
peu son parti et voici que les militants
rejette une motion pour reconnaître les
changements climatiques
je vais commencer avec vos élèves c'est
quand même une gestion très bien lui dit
je ne changera pas j'aurai un programme
mais quand même
ah oui totalement et c'est un camouflet
total et puis les libéraux doivent
tellement se frotter les mains en ce
moment parce qu'ils pourront brandir ce
vote là quand même ses 54 % des
militants qui ont refusé de reconnaître
que les changements climatiques sont
réels je pense franchement que mesure
o'toole vaut passer autre va présenter
le plan qu'il avait en fait parce que il
faut garder à l'esprit que les militants
conservateurs ne sont pas le reflet de
l'électorat au complet mais quand même
ça va lui faire mal et il ya aussi une
autre petite phrase que monsieur où tout
le dinh ans a dit dans son discours de
vendredi soir lorsqu'il a dit quelque
chose comme aussi important que soient
les changements climatiques remettre
l'économie sur les rails est encore plus
important et donc il crée une ire archi
entre ces deux objectifs alors que du
côté libéral on n'arrête pas de nous
dire que environnement et économie vont
de pair
donc une décote obtenue est bien planté
pour la campagne oui c'est ça christian
we have rendent vraiment c'est un
désastre pour monsieur autour et c'est
d'autant plus regrettable pour lui que
pour le reste sa prestation était quand
même assez réussi en fait si adroit
matin à 6 comme un désaveu de son
autorité un certain niveau comme chef
qui est remise en question
alors qu'on s'attend de plus en plus à
une campagne électorale donc ma
sympathie moi j'ai toujours eu
pour lui sans le connaître à ce point
love iii qui avait l'air d'un modéré
mais là c'est comme si justement il y
avait trop de regret et son projet de
recentrer le parti conservateur bat au
niveau symbolique qu'il ya eu un échec
avec l'attend en fin de semaine et
martin les les passages tout en douceur
et les échanges de mots doux à monsieur
le guen mais ce trudeau ça va pas le
réjouir non plus parce qu'il comptait
peut-être sur la colère de monsieur
legault vis-à-vis les libéraux fédéraux
pourra faire avancer ses pions au québec
bah je pense que monsieur legault un
meilleur flair politique que monsieur
autour je pense qu'il ya compris assez
vite là que ça serait assez difficile il
va commencer son congrès quand même
affaiblie
généralement un congrès surtout que nous
on en a connu ici d où le lot parti
québécois où ce n'est pas toujours
facile de faire rouler la balle dans le
sens où le chef le voulait mais
généralement torts gagner ça comme du
papier à musique il ya des fausses notes
ici et là que la proposition soit venu
du québec des gens sont étonnants il y
aurait fallu qu'ils viennent de l'ouest
pour être capable de la tâche est
correctement et même dans les années où
moi j'étais dans l'ouest je me souviens
de ralph klein décédé aujourd'hui qui a
fait la guerre ou à l'accord de kyoto
qui avait quand même appuyer un manuel
du changement climatique
c'est un tabou rappelle vraiment ils
pouvaient voter pour ça ça non plus
adopté le programme du parti vert on
s'entend merci beaucoup à vous trois au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit